[Music]
senator ron johnson's committee issued
its
first subpoena in the biden burisma
probe if you recall hunter biden worked
for a gas company
blue star with ties to ukraine and the
probe will look into whether the obama
administration's actions in ukraine were
corrupt
simultaneously senator lindsey graham is
looking into the origins of the russian
collusion probe
and this could be a major strategy for
republicans in november
but the big question is it a winning
strategy let's ask our company
republican strategist adam goodman
and michael knowles host of the michael
knowles show gentlemen thanks for being
here with us welcome back
thank you all right so let's kind of
break this apart first and i think the
key thing
that i want to talk about is not whether
it's the right thing or whatever that's
that's a whole separate discussion
but is it a politically smart thing so
let's start with what senator ron
johnson of wisconsin is doing
in the homeland security committee he's
looking into this whole
biden hunter biden barisma deal where he
got paid 50
000 a month to sit on a board of a
company that he had absolutely no
experience to be on
and whether or not there was any concern
there so he wants all these documents
so michael let me start with you is it a
good idea to go
down this rabbit trail will it pay off
for the republicans and ron johnson to
be doing this
i think it's a politically very wise
strategy going into november you know
the democrats have nominated joe biden
because
in many ways he's like the absence of a
candidate you know he's a total empty
suit you can put on him
whatever you like and what the
republicans are showing is that perhaps
there's some serious corruption that has
gone here you had the leaked audio that
just came out of this phone call between
joe biden and then ukrainian president
poroshenko talking about
a deal in question to fire the
prosecutor who may have been looking
into hunter biden
so i think it stinks to high heaven you
know william barr the other day the
attorney general
said that we don't want to get into a
situation where we've got criminal
investigations of political candidates
and i think that's
very true the trouble is if you've had
investigations from the democrats into
republicans
then we can't unilaterally disarm i
think it plays very well for the
president
so so adam my thought though is i get
exactly what michael said right and it
kind of can expose a lot of stuff but i
also feel right now this is kind of like
the tara reid situation which is
everybody who is agreeing with the trump
folks that we need to do this is already
with you
and the people who you know aren't going
to be with you are never going to be
persuaded by that or do you think that
there are
persuadable people that will say based
on what michael just said there's this
corruption there
i'm now not considering voting for joe
biden
well i agree with everything michael
just said but can we just talk about the
straight politics of this
i'll tell you why it's a good thing uh
for the president's re-election number
one it's going to fire up the base
uh this kind of investigation uh
always gets people's attention uh and it
will certainly
uh get uh the the wrapped attention of
the the trump
base and republicans who want to
re-elect and number two
is it's gonna force joe biden to defend
himself uh on turf that he's gonna be
very shaky on
and we've seen already in the early
debates in particular democratic debates
how how bad i think joe biden has been
on his feet
when he's under attack all of which
leads to number three
which is what this is all about we to
this point have
really seen nothing but a one-person
race it's been a referendum on the
president of the united states and most
especially on his handling of kobe 19.
it's about to become
a two-person race and i think that's all
to the advantage of the president
because when that starts to happen when
a real campaign is under foot
then we start to hear the the largely
untold and unknown stories of joe biden
one of which is what we're talking about
right now and gentlemen i think you both
make really good points
that it definitely will fire up the base
it could put joe biden on the defense
but i think an interesting point that i
still wonder is
do democrats actually care do they get
riled up like this and to shawn's point
look at the tara reid situation when you
have democrats coming out
saying i don't care if tara reid is
right
i'm still going to vote for joe biden i
want a coronation of joe biden and so to
this point
does it move the needle for the people
that are the swing voters are they going
to care enough
or are republicans just going down a
rabbit trail here
and just firing up the base and it makes
no effect at all to those swing voters
michael
i think it is demoralizing for some
swing voters and
for some democrats as well don't forget
the nomination of joe biden is
demoralizing to a lot of democrats
who feel that he was you know the the
last choice they don't they don't really
want this guy they think he's
passed his prime so i agree with
everything adam just said it really puts
them
on their feet and and to sean's point i
think this election is going to come
down
more to turn out than to persuading
people in the middle i think donald
trump has had 100
name recognition since the 80s at least
people know what they think of this guy
and so if you can demoralize some biden
voters
which shouldn't be that hard to do that
that might be a good way to get things
going but really you want to fire up
your base
say you're really taking these
investigations seriously and i think
that's what we're seeing
how about you adam well i again i think
once the same campaign gets to the point
where joe biden is put
under pressure to answer for things
that's when things
i think start to slip for him uh and
again as i told you about the unknown
parts of his record
a lot of people don't know how he
repeatedly voted against uh repeatedly
voted for rather cuts in social security
uh he praised segregation issues for bad
trade deals
and i and i don't want us to minimize um
the tara reid allegation
at least seven other women who have said
that there was
everything from sexual inappropriateness
to a sexual
attack when joe biden has to answer for
these as opposed to how he's going to
get his next cup of coffee and walking
from a studio
in his den to his kitchen uh which is
where his campaign's been for 60 days
i think you're going to see a different
kind of joe biden and that is
all to the good of uh the president
is re-election and i think it will fire
up not just republicans
it will fire up a lot of the other
americans who are looking for real
leadership
yeah see right now though i would
disagree and say that yes both bases are
fired up
but the democrats aren't voting for joe
biden i think to michael's point they're
voting against
donald trump they'll vote for a doorknob
over trump right now because
they want their agenda is so threatened
michael kind of moving on to what
lindsey graham is doing which is trying
to potentially
subpoena folks to find out what happened
with all of these people that were on
mass
what the origins of the russian probe
were is that
worth going down for political
potentials
that's essential from a political point
of view to go down i mean it's essential
from a justice point of view but
certainly from a political point of view
because you we know for a fact that the
obama administration
was spying on president trump while he
was running before he came into office
and was undermining his administration
that is not something that's up for
debate the question is
who knew about it what did they know and
when did they know it
now the left is trying to defend
themselves and say that in a certain
phone call
michael flynn's name was not masked in
the first place though there were
unmasking requests earlier
well it doesn't make me feel any better
that they were spying on michael flynn
earlier than that
actually that seems to double down on
our need for these investigations
i think they're the right thing to do
and i think it's going to help in
november
gentlemen michael adam thank you so much
for your insights and we will see how it
does help in november
thank you